you guys see that coming I just saw a
commercial for Kentucky Fried Chicken
where the parents are all excited
because the two bratty kids won't sit
still at the dinner table but they got
him this [ __ ] chicken and they're
feeding it to him they're basically very
subtly saying that there's drugs in this
chicken that will make your [ __ ]
children chill the [ __ ] out and [ __ ]
I mean like you know not not the way
they mean it over there in Great Britain
you can't say that on the Comedy Store
you can say it in a comedy club over in
Scotland but you'll have a rough you'll
have a rough go of it if you say the kid
was [ __ ] over there that means like
severely mentally challenged over here
it just means you're not gonna get laid
to you 26 when you're in grad school
looking over a [ __ ] cadaver right
with some other [ __ ] nerd nerd right
and you're just sitting there going you
know the ankle bones connected to the
knee bone right has any of this made any
sense what shouldn't it's [ __ ] Sunday
night and I am spent and I got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] I have to do tomorrow so I
got to do it tonight all right I'm off
my game
all right you cleanse your liver in like
40 to 43 days or something like that
every drunk I knows has told me that
every drunk I know that does not have a
medical degree has told me that if you
go forty to forty three days you will
cleanse your liver at least of the booze
you know now if you [ __ ] you start
doing blow or you know eating a bunch of
trans fat [ __ ] food or feeding your
kids Kentucky Fried [ __ ] chicken
Jesus Christ what happened to parents
but you got a drug your kids to keep him
under control you know you know what if
kids don't respect their parents they
respect him but they don't respect like
oh my god this this person could wring
my neck could pick me up by my hair or I
could grab a paddle and [ __ ] you know
mostly hit my ass but also kind of hit
my lower back because I'm squirming
right that doesn't exist anymore so now
these kids are so [ __ ] out of control
these pee
people have to go down a Kentucky Fried
Chicken okay and I use the term chicken
very loosely to go down and whatever
that is that's in that bucket okay if it
doesn't have a beak but doesn't have
feet if it's [ __ ] you know chest is
breast is sticking out like the cast on
[ __ ] what was what was that show with
the Italians they're on New Jersey short
Jersey Shore right my world that's not a
[ __ ] chicken you know you want the
chicken that looked like Mark McGwire in
his rookie season you don't want to eat
the chicken that looks like Mark McGwire
when he [ __ ] played for the Cardinals
you know if you eat a regular [ __ ]
chicken first of all it's gonna look
like a pigeon to you because you're so
used to seeing those roided-up once that
they have murderers row that you got
down there it's your [ __ ] Shahs right
your Vaughan's you JC Penney's whatever
the [ __ ] you buy you goddamn chicken you
go down you go down to any one of the
mainstream [ __ ] supermarkets okay and
I swear to God when you get to the
chicken section okay
if you've if you've slept for the last
thirty years like that Van Gundy guy
under the bridge whatever his [ __ ]
name is Van Morrison the hell's his name
Rip Van Winkle right it was one of those
people one of the vans if you slept for
the last 30 years and you went down okay
and they showed you what a chicken was
you'd be like you'd be like that ain't
no chicken okay that's a goddamn turkey
I know [ __ ] time no can't be done no
sir no sir
get off my property okay I'm done with
your witchcraft okay yeah take it the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] off my property
I wanna get the gun yeah you would think
it was a [ __ ] turkey and the thing is
is now it's a chicken and I remember I
watch one of those food inks one of
those [ __ ] liberal goddamn thinks you
know talking about flying carpets and
electric roads and all that [ __ ]
somewhere in there they were talking
about you know the food supply and how
poisonous is poisonous poisoning is is
so I [ __ ] went down to a farmer's
[ __ ] market and I said I wanna I
wanna I wanna all I want I wanna I want
an all-natural [ __ ] chicken I can't
even talk I'm so tired one an
all-natural chicken the guy goes these
are all-natural and I said all-natural
and he goes well I'm like come on where
is it and he had to walk around the
corner sitting over there lonely I swear
to God looking like a dove look like and
somebody killed the [ __ ] thug he goes
right there that one right there is 100%
all-natural nothing's wrong with it and
I was like I was like what at what
that's what a chicken's supposed to look
like and he raised his eyebrows and he
kind of put his lips together so they
were a straight line and then he nodded
you know that look that people do like
like yeah I'm in the matrix I realized
I'm in the matrix but you know I knocked
the [ __ ] up so I gotta be selling these
roided-up chickens no anyways any what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about so basically
that's what these people are eating over
there okay there they are drugging up
their kids but I can't get mad at them
because I actually did that to Charlie
Murphy and donnell rawlings I've told
this story before hey I'll tell it
against my [ __ ] podcast I actually
drug the exact thing that they're doing
in that Kentucky Fried Chicken
commercial where they're trying to get
their kids to sit still by just feeding
him so full of these [ __ ] trans fats
from these roided-up be class [ __ ]
chickens with their dolly parton
breasteses right
I did that to [ __ ] Donnell and
Charlie I was hungover and we were
taking a car service from Chicago as a
knees up to one of those whatever the
[ __ ] it was Saint Charles it was a three
city run and one of them was Saint
Charles so we're getting in the [ __ ]
limo Don ELLs in rare form
Charlie's in rare form they're [ __ ]
gabbing and thrashing people and me and
everybody and I just don't want to hear
it I'm like I don't want to listen to
these [ __ ] guys running that goddamn
yaps in the back of this car the whole
[ __ ] way up I want a nice quiet ride
this is gonna suck and I walked outside
hungover
and I walked into the Chicago where you
know almost got hit by three fat people
and I looked up the street and I saw it
I saw Popeyes and I was like oh thank
god and I [ __ ] walked in there and I
got all this [ __ ] popeyes chicken
with biscuits and all of this [ __ ] food
and I brought it back to the car and as
the car pulled up they came out I say
guys I got herself some [ __ ] out of some
food and they la that's [ __ ] great
you know they were hungry or whatever
and they started showering that [ __ ]
Popeyes food and I sat back nibbling on
a drumstick and I swear to God
ten minutes later they were asleep I'm
not lying
they were [ __ ] asleep snoring the
whole way up and I was just sitting
there loving life the whole [ __ ] ride
up and I you know what I admitted to him
later they thought it was funny but
that's basically what it is they called
it the itis that's what they call it
when you eat that [ __ ] food and then you
have to go to sleep they call it the
itis I guess and by day I meet African
Americans they call it the [ __ ] itis
and that's what they got they I learned
that from Donnell because I don't know
how that man stayed in shape but he had
the worst diet he's one of those guys
who like you stop for gas and he comes
out of the gas station with like one of
those
gas station hotdogs and he would eat it
and then he would immediately fall
asleep and I got I would say to Charlie
this guy he's sleeping and I've got a
man he got the itis and he explained
that to me and with that little bit of
information it went into my evil white
brain and I drugged my two
african-american friends way back in the
year 2005 and that's a little chicken
story for you once how'd you like that
everybody so that's what the [ __ ]
they're saying right there that's what
Kentucky Fried Chicken
is allegedly saying I guess I have to
say alleged so they're lawyers on
retainer don't attack my [ __ ] podcast
as far as I can tell I'm asking you
right now Kentucky Fried Chicken hiding
behind your [ __ ] letters KFC is that
what the [ __ ] you do is that what you
saying if you got kids who are not
stimulated enough that they can't even
sit down if you haven't read I've run
them around you gotta tie your kids out
open the door you sent him out in the
[ __ ] yard God God's I'd get outside
and play that's what you do like a
goddamn one of those [ __ ] Irish dogs
that was bred to herd sheep you got to
let that [ __ ] thing run around run
around in circles go get out there take
a ball you just [ __ ] throw it out in
traffic and let the dog run around
dodging cars it comes in its gonna lay
down okay it's not gonna jump all over
company sticking its Colt nose right in
there [ __ ] whoo hush that's what you
got to do with your kid you got to send
him up side right but to catch a
predator and all these other [ __ ]
shows you know all these shows on TV
where people forget their kids are in a
car with the windows rolled up that kids
are too [ __ ] dumb to roll them down
or they're too weak because they haven't
gone outside and climbed a [ __ ] tree
and they stay in there and then their
brains get cooked like a boxer you know
you know that dog boxers they don't they
don't do well in the Sun well we'll need
to do fat kids if you leave the windows
rolled up you know and they got those
weak arms at all that I think the most
tedious things they ever did was
take a wrapper off of a [ __ ] and
ice-cream sandwich right you can't leave
them in the car my mother left us in the
car all the [ __ ] time she would go to
school she was going to school during
the day trying to further her education
and she left five [ __ ] kids in the
car with the windows rolled up in money
for Burger King and she would say to us
just go into the burg that's the only
time you were to leave this car over the
left over the next three [ __ ] up when
I'm in class and she would disappear
around the corner after we said
absolutely mom and she walked away and
we immediately would get out of the car
start walking up and down the streets in
Boston we going to [ __ ] Burger King
and we'd have some to eat do you know
what would happen nowadays they just saw
five [ __ ] dirty face kids walking up
and down calm F Boylston Street going
into a Burger King looking like the cast
of [ __ ] Annie someone would have
filmed it and my mother would have been
they would have taken us away you know
but but they didn't because there was no
cameras back then or video tape ones I
mean there was but only people add him
in like the news and a young Steven
Spielberg so we went in there we [ __ ]
got some food climbed on cars and
[ __ ] yelled at people and [ __ ] you
know hanging on Park parking meters and
all that hence we had the [ __ ]
forearm strength to roll down the
windows and none of us ever had an issue
in the car and you know what I think
that's one to grow on
so there you go people I'm not saying
KFC is food I'm not I'm just kidding I'm
not saying it's bad food every once in a
while who's kidding home every once we
great if he could just [ __ ] do
heroine the way you can eat McDonald's
just like every once in a while he'd
just be like you know what yeah let's
just [ __ ] tie off not off for the
rest of the [ __ ] day and like the
people at work understood it you know
hey where were you yesterday ah yeah I
got this black tar heroin came in you
know hadn't done it like three months or
what hey figured [ __ ] it
oh is that what you did how was it I
wasn't you know like you went to a rube
he said I thought it was awesome [ __ ]
I don't remember [ __ ] but you can't you
know you get addicted to it